the other way that they leak all of this
stuff in and this is probably the most
pernicious way is through entertainment
is through culture that's why Politics
as Andrew Breitbart said is Downstream
from culture you capture people's
imaginations first through media and
movies and television and video games
and everything else and then the the
political stuff is just sort of easy to
get into their system because you've
softened them up so you may have seen
this video this is really nuts over the
weekend
was Miss Universe okay I don't really
care for these things very much but they
had the Miss Universe Pageant Miss
Universe's new owner is a dude
the only thing is he's a dude who
dresses up like a chick and has boobs
and wears lipstick but the person that
I'm about to show you is Miss Universe's
new owner
and again this is a dude
dressed up as a chick
sort of like a Mrs Doubtfire situation
enjoy the Miss Universe organization
from now on is on it's gonna be ran by
women
owned by a trans woman for all women
foreign
to celebrate the power of feminism for
all women I am a robot I am a dude chick
robot I am a woman feminism for everyone
even though I have a wang
lordy lordy lordy but it just keeps
coming and you can see how these things
are all connected right the gender stuff
like it's all just gross what how does
that dude and then the women we could
have showed you a much more extended
version of it all she's going then the
future is far away man women will be in
charge even though she's not a woman and
then all the women stared up oh my God
that's a woman I guess or something
foreign
[Music]